[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat en direct de l'hôtel de ville de
paris où se tient la 17e conférence des
villes
le rassemblement annuel de france
urbaine l'association d'élus qui réunit
les métropoles et les grandes villes
un rassemblement qui se tient à quatre
jours des sénatoriales dans un contexte
de grogne des élus locaux
remonté contre les annonces du
gouvernement notamment sur l'annulation
de 300 millions d'euros de crédits aux
collectivités territoriales la baisse
des contrats aidés ou encore la réforme
de la taxe d'habitation et de philippe
le premier ministre est donc venu ce
matin ouvrir cette dix septième
conférence des villes il était là il ya
quelques minutes avec un objectif
défendre ses réformes et rassurer les
élus locaux
je vous propose tout de suite d'écouter
son discours en intégralité
monsieur le président de france urbaine
sur jean-luc monsieur premier adjoint au
maire
javaudin julia mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires mesdames et messieurs les
maires présidents de métropole et
d'intercommunalités monsieur le
président du comité des finances locales
mesdames et messieurs vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure monsieur le président des
cartes que vous alliez analysé dans la
suite de la matinée
john keegan qui est certes anglais mais
qui est néanmoins des plus grands
historiens militaires de notre temps a
coutume de dire qu'il ferme
immédiatement un livre lorsque ce livre
commence ou lorsqu une phrase même de ce
livre commence pas si à waterloo quelque
chose si à waterloo grouchy était arrivé
en avance 6 à waterloo plus cher était
arrivé en retard 6 à waterloo la pente
avait été moins forte
sia waterloo la carte utilisée par
napoléon avait été été plus précise je
ne vous parle pas de waterloo parce que
waterloo arrive après les 100 jours et
que comme nous sommes le 20 septembre
nous devons être pas très loin des 100
jours de la majorité parlementaire
je vous en parle parce que cette
question de cartes est intéressante
on connaît au moins un exemple ou si la
carte avait été plus précise le drame
aurait été moins grave
elle se passe pendant la première guerre
mondiale en plein front de l'est
le conte alfred korzybski comme nombre
de ses compatriotes polonais a rejoint
les rangs de l'armée russe pour
combattre les troupes allemandes
et il prépare son plan d' attaque en
étudiant précisément une carte d'état
major évidemment détaillé sauf qu'
aucune de ces cartes d'état-major
évidemment détails et ne mentionne la
présence d'un fossé profond et au petit
matin les mitrailleuses prussienne qui
sont abrités dessine son bataillon
alors vous allez penser qu après
waterloo la destination d'un bataillon
russo polonais au petit matin apporte
une touche peut être un peu morbide à
cette réunion qui dans des salons
prestigieux et dans un esprit évidemment
amicale et très loin de tout cela mais
n'y voyez pas le ne voyez pas le
quelconque appel à une morbidité qui
n'est pas dans ma nature
quand il sera exil aux états unis par la
suite parce que coors ips qui ne ne sera
pas décimer lui par cette charge il
deviendra un scientifique un philosophe
de renom à l'origine d'une maxime qui
est désormais célèbre et qui me fait
penser à la phrase que vous avez indiqué
tout à l'heure
cher jean luc la carte n'est pas le
territoire
et c'est cette maxime qui a donné le nom
à un livre célèbre d'un auteur qui ne
l'est pas moins
il s'appelle la carte et le territoire
il ya toujours un écart entre la réalité
et la représentation que nous en faisons
l'état à des cartes
il ya beaucoup de cartes et il s'emploie
soit en actes allant à élaborer des
plans de bataille mais nous savons
d'expérience vous ici tous moi aussi
que la carte n'est pas exactement le
territoire et que pour gagner ces
combats l'état doit s'appuyer sur ceux
qui connaissent ce territoire c'est à
dire sur vous qui êtes au plus près du
terrain
nous avons besoin que vous disiez la
situation précise vécu partagé de vos
territoires pour qu'ensemble nous
puissions vrai le plus intelligemment et
le plus efficacement possible au service
de tous les français dans une
articulation entre vision globale et
réalités locales qui soit la plus fluide
la plus ouverte
le plus partagé la plus confiante
possible c'est précisément la vocation
de la conférence nationale des
territoires voulue par le président de
la république que j'ai ouverte le 17
juillet dernier dans l'enceinte même du
sénat qui assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales et vous avez
eu monsieur le président l'amabilité de
rappeler que cette initiative rejoint
une des propositions pour ne pas dire
une des revendications de france urbaine
vous avez rappelé plusieurs fois
l'objectif de cette conférence qui doit
nous permettre de discuter en amont de
toutes les décisions affectant les
collectivités locales ce qui n'est pas
simple pour une raison évidente
c'est qu'un très grand nombre de
décisions affectent les collectivités
locales ne pourrait même dire qu'à
certains égards
toutes les décisions de l'état affecte
directement ou indirectement les
collectivités locales donc difficile de
trouver les purs et comme nous
commençons il n'est pas impossible que
d'immenses progrès soit encore possible
mais l'idée c'est bien de favoriser
l'exercice d'une décentralisation a fumé
agile et intelligente
il l'est pour reprendre les mots du
président de la république de nouer avec
vous des pactes girondins et le
toulousain que vous êtes ne m'en voudra
pas parler tact girona il s'agit de
dialoguer c'est la raison de la présence
ce matin
cette volonté de dialogue et ne procède
pas d'une posture elle procède d'une
conviction profonde celle que nous
pouvons celle que nous devons nous dire
les choses avec franchise
c'est le premier ministre qui vous dit
cela mais c'est au moins autant l'élu
local que j'ai été pendant plus de
quinze ans que je suis encore
modestement et que j'aurais beaucoup de
mal à cesser d'être
ce devoir d'explication france nous nous
le devons entre nous nous le devons
aussi aux français
nous le devons au fond à leurs légitimes
exigences d'une meilleure efficacité de
nos politiques publiques
c'est pourquoi j'assume pleinement de
vouloir traiter tous les sujets y
compris les mêmes en premier lieu les
sujets qui fâchent
je voudrais donc commencé par revenir
sur deux points qui ont suscité beaucoup
de débats
ces derniers temps et que vous avez
évoqué tous les deux avant que je puisse
prendre la parole les contrats aidés
tout d'abord
j'ai cité corbis qui polonais au service
des riches je voudrais citer aussi un
penseur un révolutionnaire soviétique
qui disait qu' il fallait toujours
partir des faits parce que les faits
était têtue et qu'il de mantet par ma
culture havraise qui lui permet de
revenir toujours un des penseurs
fondamentaux les faits le monsieur
rebsamen suisse et que je parle de
lénine les faits c'est que pour l'année
2010 est manager messieurs le précédent
gouvernement avait budgété 280 mille
contrats aidés là où en 2016 il en avait
budgété 450 9000 autrement dit avant
même que le gouvernement que je dirige
ne soit constitué avant même qu'ils
aient l'idée qu'il pourrait un jour être
constitué il était déjà prévu qu'en 2017
il y aurait 40 % de contrats aidés en
moins qu'en 2016 c'est une donnée c'est
un fait ne le perdons pas de vue de même
autre fait que sur ses 280 mille
contrats aidés qui avait été prévu en
2016 pour l'année 2010 est deux tiers
avaient été consommées pendant les
quatre premiers mois de l'année 2010 est
pour des raisons que je vous laisse
apprécier et qui n'ont évidemment aucun
rapport avec une quelconque volonté de
bénéficier rapidement d'un effet
statistique peut pas l'imaginer pas
possible restons-en au fait donc pour
faire face à l'urgence c'est à dire à la
surconsommation d'une réserve qui était
déjà beaucoup moins forte que l'année
précédente
nous avons ouvert dans l'année 2010 est
entre 30 et 40 mille verra la fin de
l'année entre 30 et 40 mille contrats
aidés supplémentaires
je parle toujours de 2017 et je parle de
fait et personne ici ne peut contester
ces faits ils sont là nous avons décidé
de les allouer en priorité à quatre
secteurs l'éducation nationale où
cinquante mille contrats ont été prévus
pour accompagner les élèves en situation
de handicap total l'outre-mer avec près
de 12000 contrat au second semestre
l'urgence en matière sociale et de santé
les communes rurales la situation la
situation est loin d'être pleinement
satisfaisant vous l'avez dit j'en
convient tout à fait vous avez eu à
gérer des cas difficiles chacun dans vos
villes j'en ai bien conscience
mais là encore puisque nous parlons de
fait disons-nous les choses
tranquillement ça n'est pas comme si
lorsqu'on utilise est où lorsqu'on
utilise des contrats aidés dans les
villes on ne se retrouve pas à un moment
avec des gens qui ont bénéficié de
contrats aidés qui ne peuvent pas
continuer en bénéficier et à qui il
arrive que nous disions nous élus locaux
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à vous
faire bénéficier de ce contrat aidé vous
personnellement
le contrat aidé restera mais vous
partirez sans qu'il y ait toujours une
solution pour celui qui a utilisé le
contrat aidé pour la suite et nous le
savons tous je ne crois pas que de ce
point de vue là
certaines villes et échapper à cette
limite collective
voilà pour le court terme
maintenant il faut distinguer les sujets
nombre de contrats aidés réponde
véritablement à des besoins prioritaires
cela il n'est pas question de les
supprimer et nous ne la supprimerons pas
en revanche
ayons l'honnêteté de le dire les choses
est il normal dans des grandes
collectivités publiques parle pas de
petites communes rurales je parle de
grandes collectivités publiques france
urbaine
ces 2000 communes pour l'essentiel sont
des grandes collectivités publiques
est il normal mesdames et messieurs que
des emplois pérennes et jugé
indispensable au fonctionnement de
services publics soient gérées à coups
de contrats aidés je crois pas
très franchement je crois en tout cas
c'est pas ma conviction est où là
au-delà de l'urgence des jours et des
semaines à venir
nous avons donc décidé d'une part de
revenir à l'esprit originel des contrats
aidés en les recentrant sur les publics
les plus en vue est éloigné pardon de
l'emploi la ministre du travail a
d'ailleurs mentionné jean marc borello
président du groupe sos pour rencontrer
les acteurs de l'insertion et formuler
des propositions et d'autre part de
porter nos efforts sur des dispositifs
plus efficace capable de sortir
durablement du chômage les personnes les
moins qualifiées
car derrière la question des contrats
aidés c'est la question de l'emploi qui
est en jeu c'est la question de la
politique de l'emploi que voulons mettre
en oeuvre pour notre pays qui est en jeu
voulons-nous continuer à mener une
politique de l'autruche coûteuses et
inefficaces ou bien allons nous enfin
mettre en oeuvre une véritable politique
de l'emploi
une politique ambitieuse courageuse à la
hauteur de nos défis les contrats aidés
cela peut aider à faire baisser
ponctuellement les statistiques du
chômage
je ne conteste pas encore une fois qu'il
puisse être utile individuellement cela
peut faire baisser ponctuellement les
statistiques du chômage mais dans la
durée
cela ne nous a jamais fait sortir du
chômage de masse et cela ne nous fera
pas sortir du chômage de masse et quand
je dis cela je ne fais pas preuve d'un
optimisme d'un pessimisme qui pourrait
être contestée ou louer
je me contente juste de décrire une
réalité ancienne que nous avons tous
vécu que nous connaissons tous par coeur
notre ambition
elle est différente elle doit nous
permettre de financer des dispositifs
qui favorise une insertion
professionnelle durable c'est-à-dire la
formation c'est-à-dire l'apprentissage
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
d'engager 15 milliards d'euros sur la
durée du quinquennat pour financer le
grand plan d'investissement dans les
compétences c'est là le sujet et c'est
un sujet difficile mais il est là il est
dans l'élévation générale du niveau de
compétence pas dans l'élévation durable
du niveau de contrats aidés
ce qui nous imposera de réfléchir ce
sera l'objectif à partir de la fin du
mois de septembre jusqu'à la fin du
premier trimestre 2010 8 à une refonte
globale des systèmes de formation
professionnelle et d'apprentissage qui
ne devra être mise en oeuvre avec nos
partenaires en la matière les
organisations syndicales et patronales
c'est bien évident les régions mais
aussi tous les acteurs qui s'intéressent
à ce sujet tous les acteurs qui peuvent
développer l'apprentissage et les
grandes collectivités publiques les
villes les agglomérations sont aux
premiers nombre d'entre elles parce
qu'elles exercent des métiers
elle assure des missions qui passe par
des métiers on peut développer
considérablement l'apprentissage dans le
secteur public pas simplement pour
recruter dans la fonction publique mais
pour former à des métiers qui permettent
ensuite de trouver un emploi dans le
public ou dans le privé
deuxième sujet donc maintenant la
régulation budgétaire de cet été et au
delà parce que c'est plus fondamentale
la nature des relations financières que
nous pourrions envisager entre nous là
encore repartent ont défait les faits
c'est que les dotations globales de
fonctionnement les dotations général aux
collectivités territoriales ont subi
d'abord un gel puis une diminution
continue et massive depuis de nombreuses
années mais que dans les deux dernières
années 2016 2017 des dotations
exceptionnelles avaient augmenté et
augmenter de façon exceptionnelle les
dotations exceptionnelles avaient
augmenté de 1,1 à 1,2 milliard d'euros
ces deux dernières sur ses 1,2 milliard
d'euros
nous avons effectivement annulé en fin
d'année en fin d'exécution budgétaire
300 millions d'euros
c'est une annulation de crédits qui
avaient été gelés nous avons donc annulé
des crédits gelés
puisque ces crédits étaient gelés il
n'avait pas été engagé
nous avons donc annulé des crédits qu'il
avait été engagé par personne je me
permets de signaler
mesdames et messieurs que nos
prédécesseurs avaient fait exactement la
même chose en 2016 pas sûr que le débat
avait été aussi vif
en tout cas ça avait été ne laissons pas
croire je comprends parfaitement
l'émotion qui peut être suscité par
cette décision et ne laissons pas croire
que cette décision représente une
ponction ou un saignement infligé aux
collectivités territoriales c'est faux
et cela se révélera d'autant plus faux
que vous découvrirez le contenu du
projet de loi de finances que nous
préparons pour 2018 avec tout l'estiment
l'amitié de respect que je porte au
maire et aux présidents d'agglomération
il ne me revient pas et il ne vous
revient pas non plus que je présente
dans le détail le projet de loi de
finances dont la présentation doit
revenir d'abord en conseil des ministres
et ensuite au parlement mais laissez moi
dire un mot sur le cadre dans lequel il
a été conçu et sur la fille lise la
philosophie qui l'irriguent parce qu' il
n'est pas question d'ajustements
ponctuels
il est question comme pour la politique
de l'emploi de mettre en oeuvre une
politique d'ensemble avec une vision
globale des enjeux budgétaires pour le
pays
j'ai évoqué pendant la conférence
nationale des territoires à impact
financier
je veux y revenir parce que les mesures
que j'évoque s'inscrivent dans ce pacte
et y prennent tout leur sens je ne vous
rappelle pas la situation des finances
publiques
nous connaissons tous ici l'évolution
des effectifs des trois fonctions
publiques la situation précise de la
dette de l'augmentation des dépenses de
fonctionnement
la diminution des dépenses
d'investissement vous avez tous les
chiffres et en tout cas toutes les
tendances en tête
rien de tout cela n'est véritablement
soutenable
je lui ai dit à plusieurs reprises je
leur dirais autant de fois que
nécessaire
nous devons diminuer notre montant de
dépenses publiques
le montant des prélèvements obligatoires
les déficits collectif que nous assumons
depuis trop longtemps et les
collectivités territoriales doivent
prendre leur part à cet effort et je
suis parfaitement conscient qu elles
l'ont déjà prises et nous savons tous qu
elles vont devoir continuer à participer
à cet effort pour que cet effort se
traduisent dans la réalité
et contrairement à ce qui s'est toujours
fait c'est là dessus que je veux attirer
votre attention
nous n'avons pas voulu recourir à une
baisse des dotations
nous pensons qu'il est possible de faire
autrement plus intelligemment en
laissant en quelque sorte singulièrement
aux élus des grandes collectivités
publiques des marges de manoeuvre pour
décider eux mêmes de la façon dont ils
doivent participer à cet effort
vous avez tous se vante être vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le président le chiffre
de 13 milliards de lé 13 milliards
d'euros d'économies que l'état vous
demande de réaliser sur cinq ans mais
vous l'avez dit vous-même disons bien ce
que représentent ces 13 milliards
d'euros il ne s'agit pas de 13 milliards
d'euros de baisses de la dépense locale
nous vous demandons de maîtriser votre
dépenses y compris votre dépense
tendanciel qui est en hausse
c'est très différent
vos dépenses vont continuer à progresser
mais vous devez infléchir la courbe
vous devez limiter cette augmentation et
vous devez participer au désendettement
des administrations publiques au sens le
plus global
si chacun joue le jeu si chacun contient
ses dépenses de fonctionnement et réduit
son endettement
alors nous n'aurons pas besoin de
revenir à la rigidité des mécanismes
correctifs pour les grandes
collectivités qui représente l'essentiel
de la dépense locale
on a coutume de dire que les 350
première collectivité française les
régions les départements les
agglomérations les villes
350 collectivités françaises
représentent un peu plus de 70 % de la
dépense publique locale pour les grandes
collectivités qui pèse lourd dans cette
dépense locale
nous voulons discuter dans le cadre de
la conférence nationale des territoires
d'un mécanisme contractuel qui
permettrait de fixer précisément les
objectifs à atteindre pour chacun
contractuellement pour chacun et de
prévoir les conditions dans lesquelles
dans l'hypothèse où ce mécanisme
contractuel ne seraient pas respectées
il pourrait donner lieu à une
récupération ou à une correction soit à
l'intérieur de l'année en cours soit
éventuellement l'année suivante
de même nous attendons de ces grandes
collectivités qu'elles respectent une
règle d'or renforcée afin là encore
d'améliorer les trajectoires de
désendettement c'est du bon sens
budgétaire le pari que nous faisons avec
gérald darmanin le ministe de l'action
des comptes publics
c'est un pari de confiance ça n'est pas
le rabot que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure monsieur le président
ça n'est pas la baisse ex ante et des
dotations versées par l'état aux
collectivités territoriales
c'est la définition collective et
contractuel d'un mécanisme qui fixe des
objectifs et qui permet d'atteindre des
résultats je crois nous devons dames et
messieurs être à la hauteur de ce pari
nous devons d'y être parce que si nous
n'y étions pas le retour de bâton serait
d'autant plus fort pour nous tous en
2019 et dans les années qui suivent
en attendant que prévoyons nous pour le
projet de loi de finances 2010 8 et bien
après trois ans de baisse nette de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement de
l'ordre de 9,3 milliards d'euros
les concours financiers aux
collectivités territoriales ne
baisseront pas en 2018 comme ça je vais
le redire
passe comme ça ce sera clair les
concours financiers aux collectivités
territoriales ne baisseront pas en 2018
ils seront même si on les prend tous
ensemble en sanglots balle de près de
384 millions d'euros ce qui sur
l'ensemble est assez pop
ils ne baisseront pas c'est un choix
politique très fort du président de la
république
c'est un engagement très ferme du
gouvernement concernant l'investissement
public local nous savons combien il est
important pour notre croissance
économique
c'est pour tous c'est pourquoi l'état
continuera d'investir massivement sur
les territoires nous avons décidé de
pérenniser les dotations
d'investissement qui avaient augmenté de
manière tout à fait exceptionnelle ces
deux dernières années elles seront
mobilisés pour pousuivre pour poursuivre
par dont les contrats de ruralité pour
accompagner notre politique de
dédoublements de classes à l'école
primaire et pour financer des
investissements nécessaires à la
transformation de l'ensemble des
territoires
vous avez besoin de prévisibilité sur
vos ressources
c'est tout à fait normal nous devons
donc engager ensemble une réflexion
globale sur la fiscalité locale
cela fait partie des sujets de la
conférence nationale des territoires
gelé indiqué et c'est dans ce cadre que
s'inscrit la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation
quelques mots sur 7 sur cette taxe je
pense profondément que elle constitue un
impôt doublement injuste non parce
qu'ils pèsent particulièrement lourds
sur les classes populaires et moyennes
ensuite parce que la taxe d'habitation
est souvent plus élevé dans les communes
pauvres que dans les communes riches qui
ont d'autres ressources à leur
disposition
enfin parce que à l'intérieur même d'une
commune et surtout des grandes
l'injustice est patente lorsque les
évolutions respectives des quartiers
n'ont pas donné lieu à des évolutions
différenciées des bases et ne peuvent
pas donné lieu à des définitions
différencier de taux
j'ai vécu aux arbres et j'aimerais qu'on
m'indique une ville une commune de
france urbaine qui ne vis pas cela avec
des quartiers périphériques construit
dans les années soixante dix avec des
bases élevées qui évidemment n'ont pas
vu la même appréciation réelle de leur
valeur et qui paye aujourd'hui des taxes
d'habitation parfois plus élevés que
dans le centre ville on le sait tous
alors évidemment la taxe d'habitation
c'est un produit important pour les
collectifs qui est à rien bien entendu
que personne n'a jamais contestée ça
mais on peut quand même se poser et se
dire que cette fiscalité locale
c'est vrai de la taxe d'habitation c'est
vrai en vérité de toutes les autres
taxes locales est une fiscalité souvent
injustes souvent incompréhensibles
souvent illisibles et qui n'a pas de
justification que parce qu'elle est
ancienne mais que comme le dit l'adage
un bon impôt est un vieil important il
faut réparer cette injustice
il faut redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français d'ici à 2020 80% des foyers
soumis à la taxe d'habitation n'auront
plus à la payer et tous ceux qui
auraient encore des inquiétudes ou des
incertitudes à ce sujet doivent être
rassurés je le dis je le redis n'y aura
pas d'impact pour les collectivités nous
procéderons par voie de dégrèvements
c'est à dire que l'état paiera à la
place du contribuable local c'est à dire
en vérité que le contribuable national
paiera à la place à la place du
contribuable local avec un mode de
prélèvement qui sera plus juste
et dans le cadre des engagements globaux
pris par le gouvernement c'est à dire
une baisse des prélèvements obligatoires
une baisse de la fiscalité
par ailleurs à l'issue de la réforme la
compensation sera calculé en 2020 sur la
base des taux votés en 2017
pour des raisons évidentes que je n'ai
pas là besoin de préciser je préciserai
si vous voulez que gérald darmanin
précisera mais je pense que vous avez
tous compris liberté et responsabilité
nous sommes pleinement dans l'esprit de
la conférence nationale des territoires
voilà pour ce qui concerne le système le
caractère financier
le chantier du tout financier par an
tout ceci sera précisé vendredi lors
d'une réunion que les ministres de
l'intérieur de l'action et des comptes
publics de la cohésion des territoires
organisent avec le président du comité
des finances locales ainsi que les
présidents d'associations d'élus membres
de la conférence nationale de l'aide des
territoires pour les autres chantiers
initiés lors de la conférence des
territoires se rappelle que nous avons
prévu d'engager avec gérard collomb et
jacqueline gourault dont je salue la
présence une réflexion d'ensemble sur la
double question des structures et des
compétences avec toujours comme ligne de
conduite la volonté de concert de
concilier liberté locale et stabilité
globale du dispositif en promouvant un
droit à l'expérimentation a droit à la
différenciation un droit la délégation
notamment à la délégation de compétence
le rythme des réunions que nous aurons
tous les 6 mois permet deux cadencés
efficacement le travail est d'arriver à
des résultats concrets à chaque étape
plusieurs chantiers intéresse
directement votre votre
l'association et ses membres
le premier c'est vous l'avez évoqué le
renforcement de l'articulation entre
métropole et départements
je souhaite que passer les échéances
électorales de ces prochains jours les
préfets de région puisse engager le
travail de concertation sur le terrain
je lui dis en juillet nous n'imposerons
pas un canevas systémique est impératif
notre souhait ce ça n'est pas d'imposer
la fusion des 22 départements et
métropoles concernées au niveau national
en revanche là où il est possible
d'aller plus loin là où les partenaires
souhaitent aller plus loin l'état
appuiera avec détermination les
démarches de rapprochement de même que
nous soutiendrons les fusions de
départements ou de communes dès lors
qu'elle réponde à l'intérêt général
les citoyens attendent ces
rapprochements et c'est en unissant
leurs forces que les territoires
concernés pourront notamment se mesurer
à d'autres métropoles européennes
deuxième chantier qui vous concerne très
directement celui de la fracture
territoriale
de ce point de vue les métropoles ont
une responsabilité vis-à-vis des villes
et des territoires qui les entoure
elles doivent jouer leur rôle
d'entraînement matière de logement de
transport de qualité de l'air de
cohésion sociale il ya urgence à
réaliser cette alliance des territoires
que vous avez appelez de vos voeux
monsieur le président alliances des
territoires qui n'a rien d'évident
vous l'avez dit avec confiance avec
optimisme avec conviction mais je
n'exclus pas que les territoires les
plus ruraux est une vision plus mesurée
de l'effet d'entraînement que vous avez
évoqué s'agissant des métropoles à
l'égard des autres territoires
je ne l'exclus pas
il m'arrive de l'entendre et parfois
avec une forme d'amertume et d'acidité à
laquelle nous devons tous se prendre
garde
dans ce contexte l'état jouera son rôle
tout d'abord en tout d'abord en matière
de traitement des quartiers prioritaires
de la politique de la ville le budget
2010 8 conforte son appui au quartier et
au renouvellement urbains
ensuite en apportant notre soutien à des
projets de mobilité de proximité qui
créent ou facilités liées entre les
territoires
comme j'ai pu le dire hier à l'ouverture
des assises de la mobilité le l'état
apportera également son appui aux
actions de nature à transformer notre
rapport à la consommation énergétique à
travers la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments publics par exemple
c'est dans cet esprit que j'ai chargé et
sébastien lecornu secrétaire d'état en
charge de la transition écologique de
travailler à l'élaboration de ces
contrats de transition écologique
dernier point essentiel de logements là
encore nous devons rassembler nos
énergies pour construire la ville de
demain les ministres chargés du logement
jacques mézard et et julien de normandie
présente aujourd'hui même notre
stratégie d'ensemble pour le logement
vous le savez on ne construit pas assez
et on construit trop cher en france
particulièrement dans les zones tendues
nous devons donc mobiliser le foncier
pour rester pour réussir à construire
des logements peu cher le foncier même
en zone tendue n'est pas nécessairement
un bien rare il faut le libérer au
service du logement et à des prix
acceptables
c'est pour cette raison que la fiscalité
foncière sera revu afin d'accélérer
nettement les constructions au lieu
d'encourager la rétention
nous relancerons aussi de grandes
opérations d'urbanisme par une
contractualisation renouvelé avec les
collectivités territoriales dans le
cadre de projets partenariaux
d'aménagement il nous faut également
simplifier les procédures et nous
travaillerons dans le cadre de la
conférence nationale des territoires
un accompagnement financier ou fiscal de
ces opérations
dams et messieurs j'ai été long mais
j'avais d'autres choses à vous dire
si l'on en juge par les 30 chantiers
identifiés à l'issue de la conférence
nationale des territoires de juillet
nous nous attelons tous ensemble à un
projet d'une immense ambition à
l'envergure inédite
il n'y aura pas de tabou nous pouvons
discuter de tous les sujets ça veut pas
dire que nous arriverons à nous mettre
d'accord sur tous les sujets nous aurons
des débats nous aurons des divergences
de vue nous aurons aussi des points de
convergence
j'espère qu'ils seront plus nombreux que
les points de divergence parce qu'au
fond nous prêts nous nous partageons la
même préoccupation de ne pas faire les
choses pour nous mêmes mais de les faire
pour notre pays
on a coutume de dire que le mandat de
maire est le plus beau des mandats je
suis convaincu que c'est vrai par sa
puissance d'incarnation par sa maîtrise
des marges de manoeuvre par son autorité
politique par sa vision le maire et
d'une certaine façon les lus par
excellence avoir été maire dans mon cas
maire du havre a été un bonheur et un
plaisir ça n'a rien à voir avec la
fonction de premier ministre et je ne
comparerai pas les deux ici à cette
tribune
mais l'esprit avec lequel un maire
façonne sa ville
est un esprit unique précieux ouvert
pragmatiques attentifs dépourvu presque
par nécessité de sectarisme politique
cet esprit insufflons le dans nos
relations
c'est mon ambition et c'est j'en suis
convaincu l'intérêt de nos villes
l'intérêt de nos petro de nos métropoles
et l'intérêt de notre pays
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà pour ce discours du premier
ministre edouard philippe qui est donc
ouvert ce matin la 17e conférence des
villes qui se tient toute la journée à
l'hôtel de ville de paris la conférence
des villes qui rassemble les élus des
métropoles et des grandes villes et à
mes côtés pour réagir aux propos
d'edouard philippe laurent hénart le
maire de nancy bonjour laurent hénart
merci d'être avec nous alors vous avez
écouté 1 ce matin le discours du premier
ministre on viens de l'entendre à
l'instant sur l'antenne de public sénat
est ce que vous êtes satisfait oui moi
je suis satisfait d'une chose qui pour
moi est fondamental c'est qu'on sorte de
la logique de baisse de dotation aveugle
qu'on a connue pendant le quinquennat de
françois hollande ou la collectivité
bien gérée était aussi mal traités que
la collectivité mal géré et qu'on ait la
capacité de passer un contrat entre
l'état les collectivités qui faillit
maîtriser la dépense qui faillit
maîtriser la dette publique et que les
collectivités bien sûr prennent leur
part dans ce travail c'est évident
simplement il faut des mesures qui
soient concertés négocier sinon c'est
l'investissement qui est finalement la
variable d'ajustement plus
d'investissements publics plus de moins
de croissance moins d'activité moins
d'emplois et pour vous elles n'ont pas
été concertés négocier ces mesures quand
edouard philippe rend le gouvernement
annonce la suppression de 300 millions
d'euros des crédits aux collectivités
est ce que c'est un geste que vous
dénoncez ce qui est surtout à mon avis
regrettable c'est que c'était quelques
jours après la réunion au sénat où le
président de la république le premier
ministre ont dit pas de baisses de
dotations aveugle
un travail de concertation sur tout ça
la confiance entre l'état les
collectivités
je pense que le gouvernement doit avoir
conscience qu'il doit la rétablir voilà
après les cinq années de françois
hollande
la confiance n'est plus là entre les
collectivités et l'état
et ça me paraît essentiel qu'ils
comprennent que la chose est à
reconstruire
ce qui veut dire que chaque faux pas
même pour 300 millions d'euros
ce qui peut paraître peu par rapport aux
dizaines de milliards de flux financiers
entre l'état les collectivités même 300
millions d'euros
c'est un accroc et ça laisse des traces
pour vous la confiance et vous dit elle
est à reconstruire mais quand on entend
par exemple gérard larcher le président
du sénat
dire que le président a raté le
rendez-vous de la confiance entre l'état
et les élus locaux est ce que c'est des
propos que vous comprenez oui je pense
qu'on est au début du quinquennat fin
prêt le président de la république a
encore le temps de créer cette cette
confiance mais je pense qu'effectivement
il faut impérativement comprendre du
côté de l'exécutif que les collectivités
locales sont dans une situation complexe
la crise nos concitoyens dans la
difficulté cinquante baisses de
dotations aveugle une réforme une
succession de réformes territoriales
hâtives et pas concertées ont tout ça
fait que on a besoin de stabilité et on
a besoin de visibilité
un peu comme des chefs d'entreprise que
demande des chefs d'entreprise stabilité
de la législation de la réglementation
visibilité des choix d'état qui les
concerne les collectivités locales les
maires dont je suis on demande la même
chose à nancy j'ai besoin de stabilité
et de visibilité
c'est je pense ça voulait dire gérard
larcher s'inscrire dans la durée pas d'à
coups pas de tête à queue pas de
changement tous les six mois de la
politique suivie philippe ce matin a
parlé de l'une de ces mesures qui fait
du bruit auprès des élus locaux la
baisse des contrats aidés
il a justifié sa réforme en disant que
ce ne sont pas les contrats aidés qui
font baisser le chômage de masse est ce
que vous voulez a dénoncé cette baisse
des contrats et des skis
ce qui est regrettable c'est évidemment
que n'ait pas été corrigé les choix du
précédent gouvernement qui avait prévu
en fait juste assez d'emplois aidés en
2017 pour tenir le temps de la campagne
électorale a pour une fois que ça c'est
dit moi je pense qu'il faut comprendre
qu'à une partie des chômeurs qui ont
besoin d'emplois aidés j'entends ce qui
a été dit sur l'apprentissage et la
formation professionnelle et quand
j'étais au gouvernement que jean louis
borloo j'ai milité pour qu'on développe
l'apprentissage et la formation
professionnelle il faut qualifier faux
diplômés pour que les jeunes et les
adultes retrouve de l'emploi néanmoins
on a des chômeurs de longue durée de
très longue durée
plusieurs années et avant de leur
proposer de partir en formation un an
deux ans trois ans de préparer des
diplômes
il faut les remettre en activité
professionnelle il y aura pas de travail
d'insertion ci a pas un volant d'emplois
aidés voilà je pense qu'il faut sortir
du manichéisme hutu pour hutus contre il
faut se dire qu'il en faut parce que
c'est souvent la première étape avant
justement un contrat d'apprentissage ou
une séquence de formation
professionnelle et un philippe a
également parlé de la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation qui va commencer à entrer
en vigueur il a rappelé un c'est une
mesure qui se fera petit à petit et qui
sera compensé par l'état
est-ce que là aussi vous croyez douar
philippe quand il vous dit ça ou vous
craignez que dans les années à venir
eh bien l'état ne compense plus la taxe
d'habitation haut niveau à laquelle lt
perçue par les mêmes j'ai cru comprendre
qu'ils allaient procéder par dégrèvement
donc on n'est pas là pour faire de la
technique mais c'est la meilleure
compensation possible pour les
collectivités mais je pense qu à deux
évolutions de fond voilà sur lequel il
faut qu'on travaille avec le
gouvernement première évolution de fond
on peut pas ainsi indéfiniment remplacer
des impôts par des dotations
moi je crois à l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités
je crois au fait que les collectivités
choisissent un taux d'impôt et sont
responsables devant les citoyens de leur
choix fiscal est donc budgétaire puis
deuxième évolution c'est les
propriétaires moi je suis attaché à ce
que bien sûr on puisse devenir
propriétaire et quand on met bout à bout
la taxe d'habitation qui va faire un
effet de transfert sur la taxe foncière
donc sur les propriétaires lisf dont on
supprime la part entreprises mais dont
on renforcerait la part immobilière et
l'augmentation de la csg quand on met
tout ça ensemble
les propriétaires ils vont prendre cher
donc je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut qu'on ait une analyse globale de la
réforme fiscale
on peut pas faire des réformes fiscales
à un moment donné il ya bien une
démarche d'ensemble et en tant que maire
de grande ville
attaché à la mixité sociale à la mixité
de l'habitat
je pense qu'il faut qu'on prenne pas des
mesures qui enchaînait décourage d'être
propriétaire on a besoin de
propriétaires parce que ils sont parfois
un peu plus attentif que le locataire
qui passe sur le cadre de vie sur le
quartier et donc sur la cité merci
beaucoup laurent hénart maire de nancy
est d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions vous allez c'est votre place à
jean luc moudenc merci de nous rejoindre
jean-luc moudenc président de cette
association france urbaine maire de
toulouse merci d'être avec nous un
monsieur moudenc
vous avez écouté bien sûr attentivement
les propos d'edouard philippe vous étiez
sur scène à ses côtés
est ce que vous êtes satisfaire rassuré
par le premier ministre ce matin les
orientations qu'il a données vont dans
le sens que nous avions souhaité sur la
taxe d'habitation où nous étions très
inquiet pour nos budgets
il a été clair les choses à travers un
dégrèvement seront assurés pour nous
donc on ne perdra pas en produits et
puis il y avait également ces fameux 13
milliards d'économies sur les dépenses
de fonctionnement
on ne voulait pas que ce soit un coup de
rabot brutale tout de suite il a adopté
semble-t-il une méthode que l'on a
appelée de nos voeux qui tient compte de
la croissance de la diversité de nos
territoires et qui donc va nous
permettre de respirer alors évidemment
les choses sont pas gagné les diables le
diable
toujours dans le détail et donc il
faudra bien veiller à ce que ce qui est
dit se trouve bien écrit dans le projet
de loi de finances et surtout dans les
contrats qui vont être signés entre les
grandes collectivités et l'état pour la
mise en oeuvre de ces économies à faire
sur les cinq ans a mené à une grogne des
élus locaux sur le terrain nous sommes à
quatre jours des élections sénatoriales
est ce qu'il n'y avait pas une part de
stratégie politique ce matin dans le
discours des deux d'affilée il faut
rassurer les élus pourrait bien ne pas
perdre complètement ces élections
sénatoriales qui s'annoncent difficiles
pour la république en marche savez si
les élections sénatoriales s'annonce
difficile pour la république en marche
c'est pas en quatre jours qu'on renverse
une tendance donc je n'ai pas pour ma
part je n'ai pas l'impression que ce
soit une stratégie de dernière minute de
sauve qui peut parce que en réalité nous
travaillons avec l'état nous travaillons
avec les ministères depuis maintenant
trois semaines sur les questions
concrètes de ressources publiques de
ressources des collectivités de rapports
financiers entre l'état et nous et que
au fond ce que le premier ministre a
annoncé comme orientation positive
aujourd'hui va dans le sens de toutes
ces discussions qui se déroulent depuis
plusieurs semaines mais l'heure de
vérité ce sera de toute façon dans
quelques semaines à peine
donc après des élections sénatoriales
lorsque l'état présentera le projet de
loi de finances pour 2010 8 et plus
encore d'ici la fin d'année
lorsque l'état signera avec nous les
contrats
si les contrats que l'état nous propose
de signer avec lui pour modérer la
dépense et pour maîtriser nos dépenses
de fonctionnement ne correspondent pas
aux orientations qui ont été dites nous
ne le signerons pas tout simplement donc
par conséquent pour moi il n'y a pas de
risque d'entourloupe parce que nous
sommes là et qu'un contrat s'associe à
deux justement jean luc moudenc on voit
qu'il ya une alliance entre les
différents présidents d'associations
d'élus vous pour france humaines
françois baroin pour la mf dominique
bussereau pour l'adf philippe richert tu
pour la rfs que les élus locaux sont la
première force d'opposition et manuel
je crois pas que c'est comme ça qu'ils
faillent le dire même si à travers le
paysage territorial français
il est évident que c'est pas la
république en marche qui est aujourd'hui
la force dominante
moi je ne souhaite pas en tant que mère
me poser d'emblée à priori
systématiquement comme un opposant
je préfère dire il ya des problèmes
concrets dans nos villes dans nos
agglomérations nos métropoles dans le
territoire travaillons avec l'état pour
obtenir le meilleur
si je me pose d'emblée comme opposants
je crois que c'est pas comme ça qu'on
obtiendra des résultats ceci dit il faut
être vigilant il faut parfois hausser le
ton ça m'est arrivé ça mario encore pour
justement dans le cas de ce matin leurs
rapports de force obtenir quelque chose
qui soit équilibrée pour les territoires
et là dessus on est vigilant merci
beaucoup jean luc moudenc on a bien
compris votre message merde toulouse
président de cette association france
urbaine qui réunit donc aujourd'hui tous
les élus des métropoles et des grandes
villes la 17e conférence des villes qui
va se poursuivre ici à l'hôtel de ville
de paris toute la journée merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis et très bonne
journée sur public sénat
[Musique]